what happened here D4 C5 with some
band-only business style yeah yeah no I
I can't believe in benoni style in uh I
mean I mean it looks very very I mean
I don't know let's say if you would go
to real benoni Black's pieces would make
some sense yeah like the bishop on the
eighth would already be a like like a
snake penonia
exactly ready for Bishop A5 Bishop
exactly depends and also Knight on G6
would not be so stupid
yeah but Magnus grabs the space yeah I
immediately in the center with E4 and
and black plays the move 56 wow I mean
we see the evolution bar hates it on the
other hand it puts some pressure on the
D5 only probably Vladimir is trying to
Castle as quickly as possible then
eventually try to open the e-file
quickly with rookie a check to to follow
yeah Knight CC okay yes
let me Castle
well I can play like G3 still I guess
well I I don't know if I have to worry
about Queen B5
I know Vladimir goes Knight G6
you know like the the house is not
burning at all he wants to keep the
castles in the pocket for the moment
yeah Bishop D2 is kind of a nice little
touch Magnus says you know guys don't
worry for me I will handle it I first go
F4 I will find a way to deal with Bishop
A5
so how yeah what is his uh bleeds doubt
Bishop A5 bleeds doubt on the board that
must have been the idea maybe let's say
can I play Bishop D2 anyway anyway yeah
so my Bishop takes uh you know I wanted
to play the movie Bishop D2 but Magnus
overruled my move already yeah he he
played Queen F2 he wants to Castle as
quickly as possible yeah yeah
I mean basically similar idea like what
what I first saw between FC about
keeping flexible Bishop on D1
yeah and also protecting some dark
squares I'm kind of liking this he takes
D5 I guess he simply wants to play E5
yeah
and then okay after D6 it's yeah no no
this is this is horrible usually you
have to sacrifice a couple of Pawns to
get that that's right there so in fact
he he did capture ed5 and Magnus played
instantly the pawn sacrifice short
Castle
yeah so okay I mean what what I'm seeing
here yeah D4 played is super scary and
uh let's take a look how quickly will
Magnus take his time or will he Blitz
out E5 does he have a very clear Vision
already what he wants it's uh going for
this initiative I mean his position
looks also very powerful very powerful
yeah
I mean I have never seen and both
Knights are heading towards this system
B6 landed I mean
complete domination for only one point
complete yeah and and let's still not
forget about this yeah even F5
immediately actually no need to defend
D5 first yeah this gives us the chance
to to focus on Magnus because that's the
other game that feels that has the
potential of eventually leading to some
Checkmate quick checkmate
F6 on the board so what we left it here
Knight F D6 yeah Bishop takes D6 Knight
takes D6 Knight C6
Bishop E2
F6 trying to break I mean good or bad
yeah black has to break you have to try
to break out yeah exactly and queen G3
yes but but then at least already even
the f file is wow Queen E7 okay it's a
logical move
no but now I play Bishop C for check
yes King h8 and now
are you ready uh but quintax G6 doesn't
work because you have Queen E6 later
yeah exactly yeah this uh this just to
highlight that yeah exactly that's of
course the main uh main plan but Queen
E6 Queen E6 blocking the diagonal yes
they will be much more cautious in the
next couple of games yeah probably huh
yeah because the only thing here and
then you end up losing after five moves
doesn't matter how much time you have on
your clock yeah exactly exactly FC
followed by Queen sacrifice Queen G6 AG
look HD Checkmate I mean how do we yeah
check on the board
simply no defense yeah and simply made
again yeah look FC on the board yeah
in heaven right now yeah this is very
nice yeah probably clear that this was
not the most reliable defense yeah yes
B5 okay yeah that maybe this is the only
uh
sort of uh
attempt there is there is no reason for
why to panic because of night before
yeah
at the very least I am Rook up and I
have a big attack yeah exactly even if I
don't give native immediately yeah just
Bishop D5 hide the bishop and nothing
changed nothing changed I mean yeah FTX
E5 played yeah Queen takes G6 most
probably yeah Queen Tech G6 because look
F6 Knight F7 check right F7 yeah but
then Queen H4 no okay Queen H4 doesn't
do anything yeah I mean okay Magnus goes
Queenie a check he doesn't want to give
this e-pawn yeah like he doesn't want to
let E4 later so he wants to keep control
of uh of the diagonal
yeah 96 sir I think he will just come
back here he will just come back yeah
and look at this uh fellows you have
insisting on giving The Rook so after 98
E4 was played Knight F6 takes Knight E4
okay it's basically game over yeah yeah
definitely
it's not too early peace up and better
position yeah but I also C5 will fall
immediately and with that all hope
all right so okay here the smoke has
cleared itself Magnus is winning no
surprises good good moment for us to
move yeah and by the way yeah it's
Magnus Carson has one vladimiroshi I've
designed no surprise is there
so all lies on Hikaru just a very quick
update on